sale temps pour le modem après son échec
aux élections régionales une réunion de
crise a eu lieu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée
de plus en plus critiqué françois bayrou
a mis aujourd'hui les points sur les i
retour aux fondamentaux le centre
reportage de daniel sportiello et michel
anglade
ils arrivent à pied entouré de sa garde
rapprochée celle des lendemains de
défaite
la famille se réduit mais pour françois
bayrou elle est toujours présente
vous allez voir ce que c'est qu'une
famille peut l'expliquer réelle vivante
et son arrivée au conseil national
des militants manifestent leur
mécontentement après l'effondrement du
parti aux régionales
un parti qui n'a pas réussi à s'imposer
au centre de la vie politique
les gens en sont encore au bipartisme
droite gauche voilà ils ne connaissent
que la droite et la gauche et nous on
veut reporter cette voie cette troisième
voie qui doit vivre mais pour l'instant
c'est sur les doigts des mains qu'on
peut compter les élus aux régionales 10
seulement grâce à jean lassalle en
aquitaine en cause le renouvellement des
listes et la difficulté pour les
nouveaux candidats de s'imposer peu de
visages connus autour de françois bayrou
et le modem aujourd'hui compte ces élus
28 conseillers régionaux et
parlementaires seulement marielle
me rejoindre robert rochefort jean
lassalle et à l'heure de réviser la
stratégie les recentrages tout nous
sommes depuis le début convaincus que il
n'y aura pas de réponses justes à la
crise de la france qui pourra être
portée par la logique du bloc contre
bloc le le pouvoir a décidé de se
droitiser la gauche a repris son visage
de 97
fini donc la tentation de la main tendue
à la droite ou à la gauche le modem
réaffirme sa ligne d'indépendance au
risque de s'isoler encore plus